hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar querying site pine
signaling networks in
fricative neoplasms in to do work of lab
routes and I'll be moderating this
session this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on this teehee button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by fluid I'm fluid
I'm develops manufactures and markets
life science catalytic Alandra pretory
systems for markets such as mass
cytometry high-throughput genomics and
single-cell genomics food i'm cells to
leading academic institutions clinical
research laboratories and pharmaceutical
biotechnology and agricultural
biotechnology companies worldwide their
systems are based on proprietary micro
fluidics and multi parameter mass
cytometry technology and are design to
significantly simplified experimental
workflow increase throughput and reduce
costs while providing excellent data
quality fluid i'm products are provided
for research use only not for use in
diagnostic procedures to learn more
about fluid i'm please visit
www.kingston.com/support for more
hearing in presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green to an A button at lower left I now
present today's speakers Jennifer from
PhD and Stephen o MD PhD dr. frog is a
houston-based field application
scientist specializing in support and
training for flu tine math cytometry
technology she performed her PhD
research at North Carolina State
University
with a focus on method development for
ovarian cancer biomarker quantification
using high-resolution mass spectrometry
dr. Fromm completed a postdoctoral study
at the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill on post translational
regulation in diabetic and obese mice
dr. o is an assistant professor of
medicine in the division of hematology
at Washington University School of
Medicine he heads a translational
research group focused on the
pathogenesis of myeloproliferative
neoplasms MPN laboratory employs a
combination of human patient samples and
mouse models to study the initiation
development and progression of MPNs dr.
L also conduct clinical research
investigating novel targeted therapies
for n p.m. patients he completed his MD
and PhD at the Northwestern University
Feinberg School of Medicine then
completed a residency fellowship and
postdoctoral fellowship at the Stanford
University School of Medicine dr. Fromm
will now begin her presentation thank
you Judy
good morning thank you for attending
this webinar I'm going to provide a
brief introduction to mass spectometry
as we all know biology is heterogeneous
cells Express a complex array of
proteins indicating physiological status
phenotype and function in order to fully
characterize the heterogeneity present
we need high dimensional technologies
that enable single-cell analysis with
many different parameters the Helios is
a third-generation technology it's the
only single cell platform that can
measure over 50 parameters
simultaneously
these features allow one to fully
characterize the heterogeneity present
in biological samples there's five
elements of math cytometry the first
element being metal tags we use metal
type antibody to probe the cell
phenotype and functional status the
Helios can resolve Institutes of
different
process whose minimal signal overlap and
as shown in the mass spectrum down below
at the of the slide the tags have very
similar intensities all of these
features combined facilitate high
dimensional analysis and panel design as
I mentioned we use rare earth metals to
add two antibodies and probe cellular
function and phenotype the metal tags
are rare earth metal metals which means
that these are not found biologically
not found naturally within cells and so
there's no worry of cellular background
we have over 600 pre conjugated
antibodies in our catalog these
encompass both human and mouse
specificities as well as phenotyping and
functional applications if the antibody
of inter of your interest is not in our
catalog we have conjugation and services
available in which we will conjugate a
metal tag to an antibody of interest we
also have metal conjugation kits
available in which you can do the
conjugation yourself in addition to our
antibodies in our catalog we also have
cell ID regions and these include a DNA
interpolator which helps us identify
single cell events we have a live dead
indicator cisplatin an S phase indicator
and we also have bar coding reagents bar
coding allows one to combine 20
different samples into one tube and run
them at the same time this significantly
reduces variation from sample handling
and also any instrument variation that
may be present so after you decide on
your panel with your metal tag
antibodies you then danger's cells with
protocols we have protocols available as
and many of these protocols are very
similar to what you would do in flow
cytometry so after the cells are stained
with metal tags in a
a single cell suspension is then
injected into the mass spectrometer
where the Helios ionizes each cell the
Helios uses time-of-flight technology
that focuses isotope tags into discrete
bands these bands are resolved by the
detector within one Dalton resolution
thereby isolating probe signals to
individual channels whose very little
overlap there's 135 channels that can be
measured today and so this encompasses
all of the middl tags that we have
available as well as allows for room for
more tags as they become available the
Helios generates multiple metric data
for a large number of cells per sample
and this allows you to fully
characterize the sample heterogeneity on
a single cell basis since 2008 we have
over 200 publications using mass
cytometry this number is steadily
increasing and many of these
publications cover a wide range of
research and dr. o will go into one of
these areas related to cytokine
signaling further thank you for your
time thank you dr. Fong for that
informative presentation
I will now turn the presentation over to
dr. o all right so first I'd like to
thank
lab routes and fluid I'm for hosting
this webinar and for the opportunity to
present my research today the title of
my presentation is querying cytokine
signaling networks and
myeloproliferative neoplasms and this is
a general overview of my talk so I'm
going to spend a few minutes covering
some background and discussed the role
of aberrant signaling in myopic
neoplasms or MPNs
and then I will spend a quite a bit of
time talking about how we've used mass
cytometry to interrogate altered
signaling networks
the NP ends and how that has led to our
identification of hyperactivated
nf-kappa B pathway signaling in
myelofibrosis and secondary acute
myeloid leukemia and then lastly I'm
going to tell you about some very recent
work where we're trying to better
understand the interplay between
inflammatory cytokines and how they
interact with the dysregulated signaling
that we have observed in the MPM s so
just a very basic background first of
all we work on my low positive neoplasms
in my lab and this is a schematic
showing the organization of the
different myeloid neoplasms and there
are actually several different types of
MPNs
but we're primarily focused on these
three NPN subtypes polycythemia vera or
pv essential thrombocythemia or ET and
primary myelofibrosis or PMS and these
three diseases share several clinical
features but they are distinct in other
ways as well and that is delineate a
little bit on this next slide so in the
case of polycythemia vera the cardinal
clinical feature is increased red blood
cells or an elevated hemoglobin measured
clinically and in the case of ET and
sort of analogous fashion increased
platelets both of these diseases to
patients are at risk for thrombosis as
well as paradoxically bleeding and in
both cases for PV and ET patients are at
risk for eventual transformation to
secondary myelofibrosis myelofibrosis
can also occur de novo which case it
would be considered primary
myelofibrosis and this disease is fairly
complicated but comes with a number of
different symptoms and clinical features
including of course underlying bone
marrow fibrosis constitutional symptoms
which can be quite severe extramedullary
hematopoiesis and splenomegaly it's well
established in myelofibrosis as well as
in the other MPNs that inflammatory
cytokines including TNF alpha
our overproduced and it's thought that
these cytokines play a role in the
pathogenesis of these diseases though
it's not completely understood exactly
how they contribute in the case of
myelofibrosis patients with this disease
can evolve to secondary acute myeloid
leukemia and patients with T V and et
can go through a mild fiber otic stage
and then develop secondary AML but they
can also directly transform
secondary AML the prognosis for
myelofibrosis is limited and for
secondary am out it's somewhat dismal in
contrast to pv and ET where overall the
prognosis is much more favorable these
are group of diseases we're certainly
more effective therapies are are needed
so in terms of the underlying
pathogenesis of these diseases MPNs or
call disorders they're thought to
originate at the amount of what extent
or progenitor levels so this is a
schematic of the somatic product tree
and meant to illustrate that while these
diseases originate in primitive cells
they do encompass the entire myeloid
lineage such that clinically what we see
as I mentioned when the case of T V for
example elevated hemoglobin or increased
red blood cell production or in the case
of U T increased platelets the molecular
drivers of these diseases in part has
been attributed to a mutation the Jag to
tyrosine kinase so this is the jak 2 v 6
1 7 F mutation which is known to be
present in many patients with MPNs and
then more recently other genes that are
recurrently mutated in these diseases
include nipple which is the receptor
from thrombopoietin and most recently
mutations in the curriculum gene have
been identified in a subset of patients
with ET and myelofibrosis these three
groups of mutations share in common a
inability to lead to hyperactivated
Jack's dad signalling so this is a
schematic of the jak-stat signaling
pathway and denoted the jack tv6 one
zone of mutation is one molecular driver
of activation of this pathway and what
happens in the presence of Jack T V six
one seven F is this pathway becomes
either completely cytokine independent
or at least cytokine hypersensitive such
that downstream signaling is overactive
ultimately leading to increase cellular
proliferation and in the case of P V and
ETA leads to increased blood counts so
this is when the jak2 mutation was
discovered in 2005 there was an obvious
target for therapeutic intervention and
a number of small molecule inhibitors
eject too went into development and one
of these is for the drug works at MIT
which was approved fda-approved in 2011
for the treatment of mild fibrosis and
several years later for the treatment of
patients with T V so what we have seen
clinically with Russia live and similar
results in general with other drugs in
its class is that the drug is very
effective at two things in particular so
that the top graph here is showing
spleen volume reduction and in this
study patients were randomized treatment
with either relative shown in orange or
placebo shown in blue and each vertical
line represents an individual patient
with their relative change in speed
volume following treatment with R
excellent or placebo and what was seen
in this as well as other studies is that
almost every patient has at least some
degree of spleen shrinkage whereas with
placebo as expected if anything the
spleen increases in size over time which
is the natural course of the disease
once again we're talking about
myelofibrosis for this particular study
in the bottom graph it's showing symptom
response to your expletive versus
placebo and there's a pretty dramatic
difference here was the CEO of course
you would not expect any improvement in
symptoms but with rush limit there was a
substantial improvement
in patients treated with that drug and
so this has been validated across the
number of studies and in clinical
practice that ruffling them is very
effective as far as symptom improvement
and is become a very valuable treatment
option for patients with - fibrosis so
that's all well and good
however ruxolitinib and the other drugs
in this class do not really appear to be
capable of eradicating the underlying
malignant clone and by that I mean if
you measure the check to mutant allele
burden let's say it is 80% before
treatment is started and then we measure
that say six months after starting
treatment with work solid that it may
have come down a little bit say to sixty
percent or 50 percent but it will not go
down to zero and the other issues such
as the underlying bone marrow fibrosis
and the anemia that often occurs in
patients with mono fibrosis
these things do not go away so we're
certainly not putting the disease into
remission and really it's largely
symptom improvement that is observed
with treatment with ruxolitinib
so the obvious question in terms of the
underlying pathogenesis is why you know
you have a target here in a pathway
that's clearly activated and drugs that
can target the pathway so why are these
drugs not more effective well one
potential reason for this is that if we
go back to our jak-stat signaling
cascade and ask ourselves what else is
going on you know perhaps we need to
look at this sort of signaling network
as something a little bit more
complicated so here is a simplified
schematic but it gives and then gives
you an idea of really how there are many
signaling pathways which can interact
with the jak stat pathway or which could
be independently activated through other
upstream mechanisms for example NF
kappa-b
one canonical activator of F kind of D
signaling is TNF alpha and again these
pathways are all interrelated in
different ways and so it's certainly
conceivable that y-you could inhibit
jak-stat signaling with a targeted
inhibitor of Jack
- there may be other parallel pathways
which are contributing to the
pathogenesis of these diseases so our
goal broadly when we started this work
with Mouse otama tree was to really get
a comprehensive understanding of these
signaling networks in patient cells from
these patients with mild appreciative
neoplasms so that we could better
understand what's going on and then put
that in the context of treatment with
these targeted inhibitors so I'm taking
the same scream attic here on the next
slide and now outlined in white each of
these individual proteins are targets
for which there are validated antibodies
that have been used for either flow
cytometry and/or mat cytometry most of
these we have incorporated into our
quote unquote standard signaling panel
and utilize to interrogate signaling in
NPN patient samples and Jennifer gave a
nice overview of masataka tree so I
won't go into detail but just give you
an idea this this is the first large
experiment we did with mass atomic tree
to characterize signaling in these
diseases and in this experiment we had
several normal controls and and and then
for patients with mild fibrosis in
citations of secondary AML and we had as
outlined below about 15 service markers
that would allow us to resolve all of
these different cell subsets so when we
did this kind of experiment then you
know we wanted to identify these
populations of interests and we used the
algorithm Spade which I won't spend time
going into technical details that's one
of several different algorithms that's
now available to analyze the
multi-dimensional data that's produced
by the site off this just shows that
wind Spade we can utilize its ability to
cluster cells bears based on similarity
of expression across the different
surface markers in our experiment and
then as an example shown on the left
here I've drawn a circle around what is
the stem and progenitor compartment
which is in part grouped together based
on cd34 expression there's three other
examples on the right
eight showing other subpopulations which
are pretty easily identifiable by the
state algorithm and then confirmed based
on expression of markers view we would
anticipate to be expressed in these
particular compartments so we now have
these datasets with these patient
samples where we can focus on these
individual cell compartments and then
study signaling within them so when we
did this first sort of screening
experiment and looked at signaling in
these patient samples first stop was to
really look at jak-stat signaling and in
these examples I'm reducing it down to
just looking at saw so stat 3 on the
y-axis and fastest at 5 on the x-axis
and first start by showing you normal so
on the plot on the left in the basal
setting basal condition there's very
little fossil stat 3 or phosphorous 5 as
expected and then following a
stimulation with thrombopoietin or keepo
we see that there is a subset of cells
that are not positive for fossil stat3
and stat5 so that's our normal signaling
response and then when we compare it to
the patient samples here I'm showing
three examples of patients with mild
fibrosis and the corresponding basil and
pipo induced signals and what I'm
illustrating here is that the signaling
responses are variable and they diverge
from patient to patient and in some
cases they are hypersensitive to the T
post stimulation meaning a higher degree
or higher level of fossil stat3 and
fossil size as shown on the top right
but they range down to the bottom right
where in fact that particular sample
looks as and what hypo sensitive
compared to the normal and this in part
reflects the heterogeneity of human
disease there is also likely to be some
technical aspect in terms of sample
quality but I think it suffice it to say
there's there's considerable variability
in the signaling responses that we
observe and then just to show and exact
some examples from secondary ml
essentially we see similar findings in
terms of
the diversity of the signal responses to
keep up so that's the illustrate the
heterogeneity but then when we look at
these all of the samples in this
particular initial experiment and we
create a heat map now we're focusing
what I should mention we are focusing on
the prior slide as well as this slide on
the cd34 pause of the stem and
progenitor cell compartment and in this
heat map we're showing all of the
intracellular signaling molecules that
were included in this experiment and
then going down vertically from the
normal to the MF to the secondary ml
sample so everything is in terms of the
visualization is normalized to the first
normal donor the top a horizontal row
and again everything is relative to that
so when we look across the sort of this
broad survey of these intracellular
signaling markers what we found first
you know looking at jak-stat signaling
well again there's significant
variability or heterogeneity there did
seem to be a team of elevated stat 5
phosphorylated stat 5 indicative of
hyperactivated jak-stat signaling as we
would expect but perhaps more
surprisingly is that we saw a number of
other signaling markers which appear to
be higher in the patients versus normal
so as automated orange markers that are
a representative of the map kinase and
pi3 kinase pathways and then outlined in
green icon would be alpha which is part
of the NF kappa-b pathway so that was
something where we weren't necessarily
expecting to find anything specific and
once we did see something obviously it
warranted further investigation also
just to make a comment on several of
these signaling markers which were
elevated in the stem of chatter cells
from the patients with mild fibrosis or
secondary MO we asked whether these
signaling anomalies were specific to the
stem progenitor compartment were they
present and other cell compartments too
and here in these heat maps going from
left to right we're showing increasing
levels or increasing myeloid
differentiate
so this illustrates with signals being
elevated across the board in many cases
that these signaling atom values are
present across myeloid development here
is shown as an example phospho at 5 and
here's phospho kirk phospho creb and
then I gathered the Alpha so many of
these signal atom alleys persists from
the primitive cells throughout at least
early myeloid development we also in
this experiment looked at the response
to ex vivo Rex or wouldn't've exposure
so in these histograms here first we'll
look at fossil stat5 response at keepo
and we're looking at the model fibrosis
and secondary AML samples and in again
this is focused on the cd34 compartment
when we compare that to what happens in
the presence of ruxolitinib we found
that wrestling effectively blocked
almost completely the stat5
phosphorylation so it was very effective
as we would expect since Rex condom is
jak2 inhibitor and staff items
downstream of jak 2 in contrast when we
looked at the i-10 of the alpha levels
which are elevated basally and many of
the patient samples and then we asked
whether relative affected that and in
most of the patient samples there was
little to no effect from the Rexall in
other words the either the alpha
abnormally high levels were insensitive
to ruxolitinib so that really caused us
to look more closely at the F cavity
pathway and here's kind of a blown-up
illustration focus more on that and on
the right side is the canonical nf-kb
pathway and shown in orange is Ike out
of the Alpha so as I'm sure many are
aware I code the Alpha is actually a
negative regulator of NF kappa-b
activity and its role is to prevent NF
Kappa B from the NF Kappa B sub units
such as relay from acting as
transcription factors in the nucleus
and so when we think of I coyote as a
negative regular of the pathway when we
put that into the context of observing
Baisley elevated levels of that cavity
alpha we were a little confused as to
what that might mean in some respects
the natural inclination would be to
assume that that represents a down
regulation of NF kappa-b signaling but
we actually partially that was possibly
the opposite which is to mean that we
know that upstream activators of this
pathway such as TNF alpha are elevated
in patients with mild fibrosis and this
results in activated NS cat would be
signaling but then also results in
induction of negative feedback through
the increased production of I code B
alpha so one could certainly imagine
that in the face of chronic exposure to
elevated TNF alpha that in the basal or
you know sort of chronic setting in
which we measure Dyk of the alpha those
elevated levels of I cozy alpha could in
fact be reflective a chronic
hyperstimulation of NF kappa-b signaling
so you know we didn't really know
entirely what to make of it at the time
but that was some of the ideas that we
were thinking of and we also to consider
the possibility is that NF kappa-b
could be activated or dis regulating
through either or both of us all
autonomous mechanism or non cell
autonomous mechanism so cell autonomous
meaning within the same cell it could be
crosstalk from jak-stat failing leading
to N F Kennedy activation or in a non
cell autonomous fashion you could
imagine that TNF alpha could be produced
by one cell and then go and act on
another cell to activate NF kappa-b and
we actually are it's well established
that TNF alpha is a downstream
transcriptional target of Jax at
signaling as well and so that seems like
a very plausible scenario so we wanted
to try to sort that out and to do so the
first step was to modify our Masatoshi
panel and we then added in an antibody
for
the p65 r-la subunit of NF kappa-b of
antibody for the phosphorylated version
of this protein and then we went back
and did similar to experiments to what
we had done initially and what we found
is shown in these example plots on the
left here was that the levels of fossil
P 60 v were substantially elevated in
the cd34 positive cells from patients
versus controls and so shown here is two
patients with modified versus compared
to normal and here is an example with a
secondary AML patient compared to normal
so varying degrees but some some degree
of increased files of P 65 was found in
many of the patient samples and in
response 15 F alpha we also found that
many of the patients had a hyper
response to tena tough in terms of even
higher levels of fossil 50 65 stimulated
by Tina falfa than what was seen in the
normal so we did this across a series of
approximately 20 patients with modified
vs. from secondary ml this is summarized
here and compared against all the normal
controls that we use in these
experiments and we were able to show
that basal philosophy 65 levels were
significantly elevated in both
myelofibrosis and secondary MO and there
was also evidence though not
statistically significant in
myelofibrosis that in the presence of
king of alpha we also found elevated
5065 levels compared to normal so this
data you know provided pretty clear
evidence that there was NF kappa-b hyper
activation in cd34 cells from these
patients with myofibrils and secondary
mo i'm not showing it here but we
corroborated the switching expression
analysis using GSE a from an on and a
published data set and and found also a
up regulation of NF kappa-b
downstream gene targets in patient cd34
cells for patients with mono fibrosis
and then we bet wanted to understand the
relationship between NF kappa-b
hyper activation and jak-stat signaling
in other words is NF kappa-b
being active as
downstream consequence of jak-stat
hyperactivation mediated by a Jag - v6
on 7f or some other driver mutation so
we did a simple correlation analysis
between levels of sauce 1565 and fossil
stat5 and shown here there was a certain
some degree of correlation in both
myelofibrosis and secondary AML and then
we also utilize the conditional
probability algorithms REME
which looks on a single-cell basis at
the relationship between sauceless f5
and fossils P 65 and what we saw as
summarized on the graphs on the right is
that there was a significantly higher
drummy score reflecting a higher
essentially linkage between fossils f5
and 50 65 in the patient samples
compared to normal indicating that there
at least some relationship between the
two though it does not specify if it's
through a direct interaction or through
perhaps secondary mediators we also have
the question as I kind of alluded to
earlier with icoffey alpha as to what
was what are the effects of ruxolitinib
and so this is ex vivo exposure to
relative and here we're looking at the
effect on fossil fuel levels again
focusing on the cd34 cells and in that
show what we found in both ms and
secondary ml was that the russia limit
did not substantially reduce the foss
5065 levels so consistent with the
earlier experiments as i counted the
alpha there appears that this abnormal
hyper activation of the NF kappa-b
pathway is not ameliorated by jak2
inhibition we the that experiment those
experiments were with relatively
short-term exposure to excellent about
one hour and we wanted to see if longer
exposure to recommended would perhaps
have a greater effect and so we did this
for a variety of different time course
experiments up to 6 or 12 hours the
normal controls are shown on the top
here it's kind of difficult to see but
we basically found
that in comparison to the normal donors
in the case of the patients Ruksana did
not fully abrogate the elevated levels
of phosphate e65 and interestingly just
looking at the basal condition and
comparing within a patient longer
exposed longer times and cultures so in
the case of the samples on the Left we
are looking at one hour versus three
hours versus six and on the right one
versus twelve hours what we found is
that in the even just in the basal
setting meaning these cells are just
some culture in the incubator for that
period of time the fossil t65 levels
went up substantially and and that would
be potentially consistent with the
notion that these cells are producing
tnf-alpha - producing TMF tnf-alpha
and the longer you leave the culture the
more that effect is seen in terms of
just sort of basal or baseline five
fifty sixty five levels so coming back
to this schematic is far as autonomous
versus all non autonomous so again we
wanted to better understand that and so
one way to look at that is to survey the
cell populations that are effective in
terms of these abnormalities in the NF
cavity pathway so here are some Spade
trees looking at the levels of Falls v65
and this is a little bit hard to make
out but on the left side we're looking
at a normal control and on the right a
patient with myelofibrosis and these
Spade trees are color-coded for
falsities 55 levels and then the stem
general compartment is outlined here but
the main point here is that in contrast
to the normal cells in the case of the
NF sample we see at least some degree of
NF kappa-b or falsity 65 levels being
elevated pretty broadly across the
entire time at aquatic tree and this
includes T cells which are not myeloid
cells and and uh for the most part the T
cells are thought to not be involved in
the malignant clone meaning they do not
harbor the mutations such as shag QV 6 1
7 apps so therefore
specifically in the t-cells at least if
there is an abnormal activation of nf-kb
it would imply that it's occurring
through a non cell autonomous mechanism
since those cells don't actually even
harbor the malignant mutations here is
another example with an ml case showing
a similar broad distribution of NF
kappa-b signaling more so than in the
normal control and then here is looking
at another example specifically focusing
on the T cells as shown on the bottom
right and the particular patient with M
F indicating the difference between the
patient and normal and then we look also
and what happens in the context of
stimulation with TNF also here as shown
by the red arrows the most robust unis
are so NF kappa-b activation is
occurring in the CDA 34 compartment both
in the normal and in the patient so that
illustrates the point that the that
context matters in terms of the
conditions so basal vs t NS stimulated
or other perturbations may give
different results which inform the
interpretation of what's actually
happening or what could be happening in
vivo so coming back to TNF alpha I
mentioned that this is one of several
inflammatory cytokines which are known
to be elevated in NPN patients and most
particularly in myelofibrosis and we did
our own analysis looking at circulating
plasma levels to confirm that utilizing
many esteemed samples that we examined
by mass spectrometry and this graph just
shows that we did find that TNF alpha
levels were significantly elevated in
both myelofibrosis and secondary AML but
we wanted to understand where the TNF
alpha was coming from because that's
plasma so total plasma levels of TNF
alpha and so we took advantage of the
ability of mass otama tree to measure
intracellular cytokine levels and we
developed a separate antibody panel
where we measure at about 15
intracellular cytokines
in conjunction with the surface markers
to identify the different subsets and
then we can identify where these
cytokines are being hyper produced and
so these fate trees are pretty difficult
to make out but the point that is
illustrated here is that in the case of
TNF alpha which is being shown here as
well as many of the other cytokines the
most the highest production of the
cytokines was occurring in the monocytes
and to a lesser extent in myeloid
progenitors and the stem or progenitor
compartment and we looked at that more
closely so in these examples on the left
the plots are showing monocytes on the
right lineage Tango's cd34 cells and
looking at one normal versus two
patients with mild fibrosis in the basal
condition shown the top rows there were
only a small percentage of cells which
were positive 14 of alpha although that
number was at least slightly to
significantly higher in the patients
compared to the normal we also looked at
the levels of Chios and the other
cytokines in the presence of P na PMA I
know Meissen and we found that although
the normal cells responded as expected
with an upregulation of TNF alpha
production they there was a hyper
response higher levels 15 of alpha in
the context of PMA itemizing in patient
samples as well as well that is
summarized on the bottom-left graph
indicating again both in the monocytes
mg34 cells we saw increased levels of
TNF alpha we also looked at this in SLI
in the bath Riesling expressing nipple
as well as jak 2 v 6 1 7 f vs wild-type
jak 2 versus parental cells and found
that expression of jag 2 v6 on 7f was
sufficient to lead to a substantially
increased production of TF alpha
providing further support for that
specific mechanism to be in play that
jag gv6 one set of leads to increased
production of K alpha which then
activates NF kappa-b
so you know putting the signalling and
the cytokine data together we set we
asked ourselves well are these things
happening in the same or different or
overlapping cell compartments and on the
Left we're looking at faso 255 levels in
various cell compartments and we found
that as I showed earlier with the Spade
trees and the basal setting we see a
broad distribution of NF kappa-b
signaling and the presidency anahatha
it's a little bit more enriched in the
more primitive cells and in contrast in
terms of chance officer on the right
really most prominently over produced at
highest levels in monocytes so
indicating that it may be that the malla
sets or would produce the bulk of the
teens also and then they go and act on
more so that primitive immature cells we
looked at the effect of Rexel in Devon
TNF alpha levels and on the left this is
looking at plasma levels of TNF alpha
and breaking it down in terms of
patients with myeloma fibrosis pre or
post treatment and comparing that to
normal donors and we found that the
levels prereq solanum were elevated as
expected and in the presence of
ruxolitinib treatment this is
therapeutic Administration's in vivo the
levels remain they may have come down
slightly but they remain significantly
elevated compared to normal and this is
consistent with published literature
just further establishing that TNF alpha
levels are not normalized by ruxolitinib
so we wanted to look at this in the
individual cell population something's
down by site off and we here I'm showing
monocytes and again it's a little hard
to see these graphs but it's quite clear
that in the presence of ruxolitinib the
elevated levels of tena alpha in the
monocytes from patients with MS here
shown two examples were not
substantially reduced by rush leutnant
and another example in cd34 cells the
same was true that the subsets of cells
that were positive TNF alpha did not go
back to normal in the presence of
ruxolitinib
so you know I'm really focusing on
tnf-alpha nf-kb but with the side talk
we have the luxury of being able to look
at many different cytokines at the same
time and we certainly think that's
relevant given that in these patients we
know it's already been established that
many different cytokines are apparently
produced so we wanted to ask whether we
could show that some of these same
cytokines are being produced by cysts
over produced by specific cell
compartments of semana slate so focusing
right now on monocytes and these grafts
are illustrating that again Tina Hoffa
is not the only one that many of these
other cytokines are over produced in the
patient samples so highlighting you know
for instance of this patient pretty
prominent upregulation of il-6 positive
cells as well as midpoint beta and in
this other patient more so Tina's alpha
and interferon gamma
these are radar pods just to try to
summarize or encapsulate the data we
have with cytokines and each spoke of
the wheel here is a different cytokine
and then the plot the lines basically
show the relative or the relative levels
of positive cells for each particular
cytokine and the left plot each
individual patient with MF is colored
with a different color and then compared
to the normal or the average of normals
which is shown in black and the NF
average is shown in red so it's you can
see that there is a substantial
difference between the two groups and
the same data is shown a little bit
differently on the right with each
individual patient colored with the same
color light blue to try to make make it
visually more clear the difference
between the average MF and the average
normal shown in blue versus red so we've
also done some preliminary work looking
at response to different perturbations
such as TLR ligands like RA a48 or Pam
3cs k4 and basically we see similar
themes which is that in the patients
there is high production of a variety of
cytokines and this
a Polish 19 at alpha and the two
patients compared to normal and when we
look in tea sauce again I mentioned
earlier that these are not myeloid cells
are not in most patients thought to
harbor the actual mutations that are
present in the malignant clone and yet
despite that there here are several
clear examples particularly in the
presence of PMA and Ayana myosin where
there are substantially higher higher
numbers of positive cells in the
patients versus the normals on the left
of the examples nippon data on the right
interferon gamma okay so this one I
talked for a minute about what we're
doing currently with this work one area
of interest is to understand how NS
counted the activation and of course
other signaling abnormalities are you
know characterized as across the
spectrum of MPN disease states or
disease progression so we've looked
primarily at myelofibrosis and secondary
mmm were very interested as well as in T
V which can ultimately transform to NF
and then to secondary AML so we have
some initial work that we've done with
specific patients where we have matched
serial samples which has been quite
interesting and then we plan to look at
a series of additional patients with all
these different disease states we are in
a sort of the follow-on work from our
identification by massive Tama tree of
NS cavity hyper activation we're now
trying to interrogate this in mouse
models and using genetic models as well
as other systems to really understand
what this means the fact that we've
identified and had the activation and is
it something that we could perhaps
intervene and therapeutically and that's
the next point is really this concept of
leveraging this dysregulation was
pathway in other words can we rather
than you know maybe simplistically
thinking just eliminate all the
abnormality
can we actually resource these signaling
pathways to point to a selective effect
on the malignant clone
so I'm going to close with
acknowledgments and you know several
people to really acknowledge who the
critical for this work within my own lab
this project was initiated by a forum
post occupancy angle and carried on by
another postdoc Daniel Fisher and all of
the Masatoshi work we're doing currently
and recently is has been conducted
through the immuno monitoring laboratory
which is part of the burski Center for
human immunology and immunotherapy
programs or chips and I wear two hats so
I also oversee the half of the IML that
houses our to site off instruments and
Olga and Kate in particular have been
extremely helpful for this work as well
as to students in our master's in
biostatistics program Henry and Liang
before him who have contributed to the
analysis of our data and also like to
thank my funding sources and I will be
happy to take questions thanks for your
attention
Thank You dr. Fromm and dr. Oh for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box and like
clicking on in green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Fromm dr. o will answer as many
questions as time permits and the first
questions for dr. Oh what is the age
range of patients with NPN and are there
any differences in either signaling
pathway aggregation or response to
treatment associated with age so MPM
patients MPs are generally diagnosed in
patients of older age you know it
typically ages you know 60s 70s and
whatnot but we certainly see a patients
who are diagnosed at younger ages as
well we have not looked exhaustively at
the age of different patients and their
signaling phenotypes however it's it's
it's a well-known that in some MPNs in
particular and polycythemia vera which
is has not really been our the focus of
the work that was shown today but in in
that disease there are some differences
in the clinical features of patients who
are either younger or older and what's
one a separate project in the lab is to
try to understand whether those patients
have different characteristics
phenotypically and genomically and so
that's something that's ongoing dr. know
this next one's for you too about how
long did it take you to validate your
panel so that's a good question I guess
the short answer is for much of the work
that was shown here it was on the order
of six to twelve months to get it really
optimally validated the longer answer
would you know one point is it's never
done so we're always kind of tweaking
the panel considering adding new
antibodies and therefore you know
potentially swapping antibodies out
because our panel is generally pretty
full
and the work actually that that's
included in this presentation actually
went on for went dates back to my
actually about more than five years ago
partly because at that time when when
site talk was kind of just taking off
there weren't really that many
commercially available antibodies at the
time so there's much more customization
that was required these days that is the
landscape has changed considerably there
are many more antibiotic ated from fluid
ayman and and you know maybe that's
something i can throw it over to
jennifer to comment on yeah thanks Steve
yeah we currently in our catalog we
actually have over six hundred primary
antibodies we also have seventeen
secondary antibodies so if you already
have something that's labeled for flow
you can maybe use one of our secondary
antibodies most of our antibodies I will
say are human and mouse specificities we
do have some that are cross reactive and
I will say we do have several
researchers now that are using some of
the human clones that also work for
non-human primate research we also have
pre design panel kits and these are kits
that are designed to be module so you
can take say for example a phenotyping
panel kit which is meant to I D major
leukocytes then you can couple that with
maybe a functional panel like cytokine
or signaling or cell cycle kit and then
there's so many other channels that you
can add in your other favorite proteins
that you might be interested in looking
at so it really helps people get up and
going a lot faster than the early days
of math cytometry okay next one is for
dr. oh so if the defect is present in
stem cells is there any impact on the
lymphoid compartment with current
treatments and also did you monitor that
in your math cytometry panel that's a
good question so you know I think as
particularly in the latter half of the
talk I alluded to we you know these are
myeloproliferative diseases so they are
thought to start with the stem approach
Arabic apartment
encompass the entire myeloid arm but
what we observed is that in particular
we saw signaling abnormalities
specifically NF kappa-b
present in T cells and the lymphoid
compartment so we think that the you
know the diseases are more complex than
just looking at myeloid cells and that
there are lymphoid cells as well as as
well and then whether that is because in
some of those patients or some of those
cells there actually are the same
mutations present or actually it's more
through a cell not autonomous mechanisms
you know we can't say for sure based on
our results but I think s the general
point is I think the important one which
is that the lymphoid cells are likely
involved or at least abnormally
functioning as a result of what's
driving these diseases the cell
activation or staining protocols for
phospho signaling experience merriments
need to be modified when doing math
cytometry sucker oh yeah that's a good
question so I didn't I didn't go into
detail but our protocols are a little
bit different when we do when we look at
signaling or cytokines in in and in in a
nutshell when we do the signaling
experiments we use methanol to permeable
Isis cells so we do the signaling
perturbations then we fix the cells we
we stain the surface markers and then we
methanol permeable eyes and stained with
the intracellular signaling antibodies
with the cytokine experiments we use a
saponin based permeabilization and we
also do things a little bit differently
by staining the surface markers on live
cells prior to fixation so a little bit
different ideally we would combine the
two approaches so that we could measure
signaling and cytokines simultaneously
but that is something that at least
historically has been a little bit
challenging and because we have more
than enough antibodies to fill out our
panel you know whether it's either kind
of signaling we have essentially kept
them separate so far okay um in a key it
can be sorry about that thank you for a
great talk and is asking who's curious
for analysis
which program was compatible I II stayed
or sitrus dr. L so yeah so the most of
the data I showed in this presentation
was using Spade but we have we have used
most of the fairly commonly utilized
algorithms to look at our data including
Disney which is has a lot of swings as
far as analyzing this kind of
multi-dimensional data but I didn't have
anything include in this particular
presentation we've also used citrus
mostly with a slightly different project
and but we've found that to be useful in
other ways as well and we've also used
FINA graphs and a few other methods so
in general I think with with site off
depending on the question you're
answering asking and the types of
samples available there are variety
different tools that can be particularly
applicable dr. o how many secretion
inhibitors affect this kind of cytokine
data and should they always be used yes
it's another good question so that I
think that in the generally speaking
cytokine secretion inhibitors are are
used as pretty much a standard in these
kinds of experiments and the data that I
presented and in that data we use
secretion inhibitors routinely we've
done it both plus and minus secretion
heifers and generally gotten similar
results but most consistent data has
been with secretion inhibitors and we've
stuck with that again primarily because
that seems to be the standard approach
in this field do you validate your math
cytometry tunnels against standard flow
cytometry dr. oh yes so it's a good
question so many of the antibodies we we
have examined by flow cytometry as well
we didn't necessarily you know in a
dedicated fashion do a side-by-side
comparison as we are developing our
panels partly because I think pretty
much every antibody and in our panels is
an antibody that is you know previously
been validated for flow cytometry and
has you know been sold as a flow
antibody and that's something that you
know you know when I kind of wear a
couple different hats and
run the core lab that houses our sights
on instruments so often meeting with
prospective users and when we start
talking to Emma is the first thing a
first piece of advice I would give is
well is ideally use antibodies that are
already known to work for flow cytometry
so if that's the case then you know then
it's likely to define foresight tough
but in the case where someone were to
want to use an antibody where's either
not know it or not validate if I
supposed to talk to you then I think you
know you have to ask that question as to
whether it's even going to work but
generally speaking you know if it works
your flow it works for site off and once
again we did validate many of the an
Tobias for flow but not necessarily
every single one thank you and some more
audience questions are coming in I would
like to once again thank dr. Fromm dr. o
for their presentations do you have any
final comments for us yeah I think I
don't know if the presentation got cut
off at the end therefore for everybody
but you know the sort of take-home
points with with the work that I
presented today are that sort from a
more from a very broad perspective I
think I've hopefully demonstrated that
Master tamo tree is a very useful tool
to profile in particular in our case I'm
at aquatic cells where there are
multiple different cell compartments and
so we can utilize the high parameter
aspect of Master tamo tree to include
markers that can identify these
different cell compartments but the same
time have room in our panel to include
either signaling or cytokine antibodies
so that we can you know typically
profile these cells in terms of aspects
of again signaling or cytokine
production which reflect their
underlying cell behavior so in a broad
sense again the this technology has been
very useful for us and in fact you know
in thinking about alternative
methodologies when you're when you're
looking at the single cell on a single
cell level there's not really a good
alternative to be doing this with
primary blood or bone marrow cells and
the more specific sort of take-home
points on the scientific end with regard
to the mild Pusser diseases which is the
focus of our work is that we
with this approach we really on I think
uncovered that signaling networks and
these diseases are very broadly
dysregulated and really not as
straightforward as simply jak-stat
hyperactivation
and further with the cytokine work that
we've been doing more recently
understanding that the mechanisms by
which these signaling networks become
dysregulated is likely to be complex of
course but also likely to be a mixture
of both autonomous and cell non
autonomous mechanisms primarily mediated
by these altered cytokines that are
being produced thank you again dr. dr.
Fromm I think dr. o summed it up very
nicely I don't think I can add anything
other than that what he said thank you
again and I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their very
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you've provided at
the time of registration we would also
like to thank our sponsors fluid I'm for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and solve the process to
receive your credits this webcast can be
used on demand through November 9 2017
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye